Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast and just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
Um,
I have no life. I don't know what to
talk about. I got no fucking life, man.
We're just right in this God damn show,
having a great time doing it, of course.
But,
uh,
I just stay in a writer's room and I stare
at a computer screen all day long and,
uh, my eyes were killing me yesterday. Uh,
I started looking around
the room and I noticed,
I think I'm the only one in the
room that doesn't wear glasses.
That's like a, that's like earning
your stripes as a writer, as you are.
You actually, you wear glasses that, and
you can do that thing where you, you know,
you spend the fucking pen around your
finger and you can catch it. You know,
those, you know, friend of mine always
said mathletes could always do that,
you know, but, um, anyways,
I'm going to do some standup
this weekend. Uh, we just, uh,
we just did the table
read for episode two. Uh,
Dave Kepner came in and just crushed it
as Bob Pogo is fucking awesome. And, uh,
you know, that's probably my most
favorite thing about the week, uh,
is doing the table reads because it's,
it feels like doing stand up in front
of a la live like crowd for those of you
not in the business.
It's basically after you write the thing,
you sit down and before you record it,
you basically,
you do it in front of a bunch of
people, um, who've invested in the show.
So they're hoping it's funny, but if it
isn't funny, they're not going to laugh.
So if they, if you get them laughing,
if you get industry industry,
people laugh and that's
always a big thing.
So we had a great table read
some very excited about that. Um,
and um, anyways, but that's not what
I want to talk about here today.
I got to tell you something I found the
other day, uh, when I was on youtube. Um,
any wrestling fans out there?
Ah,
anybody old like me used to watch fucking
Tony, Gloria and Larry's at Bisco.
Ivan put ski and Bulldog Brower and Pat
Patterson and Ted dibiase the Internet
intercontinental champion.
You know dusty Rhodes.
Mr Fuji, Mr [inaudible], the moon dogs.
Okay.
George the animal Steele superstar.
Billy Graham.
Bob Backlund,
Bruno Sammartino.
Greg to Hammer Valentine.
I can't remember how many these fucking
guys are still remember Tony Atlas?
Okay.
Jimmy superfly snuck up.
I still remember that finishing moves.
Tony Atlas would just fucking
basically do a military press with you.
He just pick you up over his head
and he fucking throw you right Andre.
The giant would just put his
giant fucking size 48 foot.
You throw you off the ropes and just stick
it right in your face and he'd sit on
ya. I've been put ski,
had the Polish Hammer.
Greg Valentine had to
figure four leg lock.
That's the first time
ever throw out my back.
This kid when I was in fourth grade,
showed me how to do the figure four leg
lock by putting me into it and it was
fucking killing my knee and I was
trying to get up to, to get my free,
my leg from putting
pressure on my kneecap.
And as the first time I fucked up my
lower back that have bad backs since the
lower, since the, uh, bad, lower
back since the, uh, the fourth grade.
MMM.
Chief Jay Strongbow would
do the fucking rain dance.
That wasn't too fucking racist was it?
Once he did that,
he went into this crazy fucking,
he couldn't feel pain anymore and then
he kicked the shit out of you. Uh,
all right.
Enough of that shit.
So I was just looking at some
of the old restaurants, um,
stuff that I used to watch, SD
Jones, special delivery Jones,
the guy never fucking one.
He was the most coolest fucking guy ever.
MMM.
Anyways, Mr Wonderful, Rowdy Roddy Piper.
I fucking love all those
guys. So anyways, um, I was,
I never heard of this before,
but you have it.
Those of you who aren't fans of wrestling,
and there's this thing called a
shoot match, which is basically,
you know, wrestling, it's
sports entertainment.
When I was a kid they used
to argue that it was real.
And then finally they said no it's fake.
But,
but what was great was
once they said it was fake,
they could actually talk about all
the real pain that they go through.
So I was kind of just
watching some youtube videos
about that and I came across
this stuff called his shoot match.
So I was like,
what the hell is this shoot match in
a shoot match is basically a wrestling
match where they're fake fighting and
then somebody gets pissed at somebody else
and it becomes a real fight.
And what usually happens from the few
that I saw is if the person's just not a
complete roid roided up psycho.
MMM.
What it really is is either
somebody is not selling your moves,
like I'm fake punching you and you're
just acting like it's not hurting.
So you making me look like an asshole
or somebody, you know, you are,
you're allowing somebody to throw you
and do a move and they botch it and fuck,
fuck you up in hurt you
and then you get mad. Um,
I saw one with this guy.
This kid was new when he went to
to execute some fucking throw,
and this guy was just a psycho.
He didn't look like he landed that bad
and he got up and just beat the fuck out
of this guy.
Just threw him head first out of the ring.
The guy landed on his fucking head
and we immediately had a concussion.
Then he picked the guy up and threw him
into the metal stairs and this guy kept
selling. I guess he didn't have
to sell the moves at that point,
but that one was fucking brutal. But
the funniest one. But she got to see,
and I'm having a link to it. It's
the great Antonio verse, Antonio.
I hope I say it right. So he doesn't
come over and slapped the shit out of me.
I knocky.
I'm a Japanese guy.
So the Great Antonio is this,
I can't even describe what he looks like.
He looks like a fucking troll with a page
boy haircut and he's just ridiculously
fat and he's wearing the ugliest mustard
colored yellow light sweat pants with
these military boots on.
I'm just not a good looking person.
And he's a wrestling,
this guy, Antonio Anakie,
who's a Japanese guy who looks like
a fucking movie star, you know,
he's got the old school movie star Chin,
he's got the Jack Lord Hawaii
five o fucking haircut.
He's in great shape.
So they start fucking wrestling
and a Raslan and you know,
the Japanese guy is,
is being a fucking professional and
the Great Antonio who I guess had a
reputation for not selling people's
moves and being selfish in the ring,
you know,
the Japanese guy would punch him in his
fat stomach and he wouldn't even move.
And then the f the fat that it would
keep like punching his stomach like it's
hard as a rock. And people were
laughing in the crowd. The fucking guy,
like the Japanese guy throws him off the
fucking ropes and the guy just sort of
stops, you know and doesn't
sell the fucking move.
And the Japanese guys looking at him like
what the fuck? And the crowds laughing.
He starts seeing the Japanese dude
looking at him like, dude, what the fuck?
It's a long story short,
they get a few minutes into the round,
the Japanese guy has been
selling everything the fat
fuck's doing the fat fucks
making the Japanese
guy look like an idiot.
So fat fuck gets the Japanese guy against
the ropes and he's punching almost
like the back of this guy's neck.
Super fucking hard.
And the guy takes like three of them
before he finally like blocks the fourth
one and then he just snaps like,
dude, what? Like fuck this.
And he just stands up and just open hands,
slap this fat fuck in the head
is hard as you possibly can.
And the Fed pageboy guy like turns
his head, it's fucking phenomenal.
And the Japanese guys going like
go making those like come on,
let's fucking fight.
And the Fed fuck still kind of like
thinking he's just going to take one.
He slaps him in the fucking head again,
then grabs his leg,
Japanese do just snaps,
fucking throws him on his belly,
boats them in the fucking head right now
the ref is going like, whoa, whoa, hey,
whoa.
The fat fucks crawling around like a dog.
And the Japanese guy boots
him in the head again.
Now the fat guy is like fucking plank and
he's laying down on the ground and the
Japanese guy boots him in the head
like another fucking six times.
It's almost attempted murder.
The fucking dude is a bloody mess.
They finally just called a match and um,
it was one of the great
pieces of justice I ever saw.
I didn't feel bad for the guy at all
when he was getting voted in the head.
I was dying laughing.
If you saw how hard this does,
fat fuck was punching this poor Japanese
guy in the back of his neck and he,
that guy taking it like a
pro and finished. Finally,
he was just like, what the,
cause it was all, he was like,
he was hitting him for real. Um,
and he wasn't selling his moves.
So you got, I'm, I'm going to, um,
have a link for it. If anybody else
has some good ones up there. I,
it's just a whole new part of Youtube
that, uh, you know, if you're at work,
if you're bored right now, just
look it up yourself. Shoot matches.
S h o o t matches and uh,
there's just some legendary ones and um,
you know,
as much as they talked to wrestlers and
stuff, like I don't, I never hear him,
you know, I always hear, you know,
about doing the road and these,
these great matches that they had. And
then of course they talk about, you know,
you know, people get in
the sickness, you know,
getting addicted to painkillers
and drugs and all that shit.
They do all that type of shit. But, um,
nobody talks about all these fucking
wrestling matches out there that, uh,
suddenly, um, that's suddenly became real,
you know, so, um, I dunno. I hope
you enjoy it. That's all I could say.
But anyway, so let's get back to,
uh, let's get back to the podcast.
So basically everything that I'm going
to be talking about over the next couple
of months,
it's going to be whatever I look out
the window and see while we're writing
emphasis for family.
So anyways, um, yeah,
the day we're in the writer's room
actually yesterday and all of a sudden we
just hear like this fucking commotion,
right?
And we look out our windows in,
there's all these protesters just
walking down the fucking taking up like a
street, you a lane of the
street, like, uh, you know,
like bike riders do now. You know what
I mean? When they ride down the street,
if there's two of them rather
than riding single file,
they ride side by side because
they want to talk and you know,
fuck the 50 cars that are behind
him. Oh. And then by the way,
if they actually get hit, it's this major
fucking tragedy. Like, oh my God can,
can you fucking believe that happened?
Yes,
I can totally believe
that happened completely.
A bicycle is simply a
motorcycle without an engine.
That's what you're riding around on it.
But I know you dressed up like you're
in the Tour de France, you know,
you feel in a little European
like that dude and breaking away.
Maybe you're speaking in Italian and
you kind of forget that you're riding a
bicycle out in the street in Los Angeles
home to arguably some of the worst
drivers on the planet.
All right?
And I've always gone off on technology
and Shit and saying, I don't like it.
Saying like we had enough technology
somewhere around the early nineties we
should have stopped right about there.
You let people die off.
Stop trying to cure fucking diseases.
Stop.
Make a new technology that
everybody has to go out and go buy.
Let's just stop right
fucking here. Okay. I mean,
take you remember the early nineties
it was fucking great. It was fine.
Cars for fast enough.
Everything was fine.
He didn't have to go
any further than that.
Wasn't it better when everybody wasn't
on the fucking Internet? I think it was.
Even though I'm sitting here
on the Internet right now,
I'd be willing to walk away from
this shit. It's a great time.
Everything you did wasn't filmed.
It wasn't fucking recorded.
There wasn't some satellite point in that.
You're tracking you down the street
as you try to get to a dairy queen,
but also the Illuminati can fucking take
you out cause they probably own that
satellite,
you know,
turn on some chip in your car and make
it drive into a fucking tree. You know,
make white people. These are very
mainstream stories here. Um, anyways,
um,
these fucking proud.
They must have had a permit because it
was a cop in front of them in behind them
and they're just walking down the
street and I got to tell you something.
All right, I'm all for the working
man. I'm all for that type of shit.
But the second you go out in the fucking
street and you start blocking traffic,
I don't give a shit. If you trying to
save babies, I hate you and I want to,
I want to rent a cement truck and run you
over. Like I was sitting in an office.
They weren't causing me any trouble
and just the empathy that I had for the
people trying to drive around them made
me want somebody to just fish tail into
the fucking crowd.
So if you've ever been in a protest,
let me ask you this question.
Is it
the objective to not only call attention
to whatever it is you're complaining
about,
but then don't you want people to
listen
and then be like, Oh wow, I
didn't know that was going on.
You know,
so why would you annoy the shit out of
everybody by like clogging up traffic?
To me,
it's no different than fucking terrorists.
A lot of times whatever terrorist are
bitching about, I'm like, yeah, I could.
I totally understand why
you're upset about that,
but the then go and blow up a bunch of
innocent people. I'm just like, yeah,
but that's not the way you solve it.
Right.
My office simplifying this. It's like we
don't fly over there and drop bombs it,
oops. Did that land on your baby? Yeah,
we were trying to get the bad guy. Sorry.
Your baby was within a 30
mile radius. I Dunno. Um,
anyways, do you guys have that?
Do you have, do you have like,
like I actually enjoy riding a bike,
but, uh, I'm an old school bike rider.
Like I ride up on the sidewalk. I
don't wear a helmet. Um, you know,
I don't ride 90 miles an hour down the
sidewalk and I don't care when people who
walk on the sidewalk give me a
fucking dirty look. It's just like,
I'm not going out there.
I'm not going out there and traffic
because I know everybody out there is like
me and they're texting while they're
driving or they're fucking air drumming.
You know, God knows how many people
are out there on prescription pills.
To go out there on a fucking
motorcycle without an engine is,
is really fucking stupid.
Okay.
Yeah. And um, I feel like this
thing was like bike riders.
They have this thing where they feel
like they're these victims and uh, I,
I find them way,
way more hostile.
Okay.
Considering the position that they're
in and they had this whole fucking,
you will respect me and I have just
as much as of right to be out here.
What should do you do? I mean,
even though there is no bike lane,
they just painted,
painted a bicycle on the fucking street
so they could get the federal grant.
That's the reason why they do that
shit. Right. And then, uh, you know,
all right,
so you have a right to be out there,
but then you have to obey the rules
of the road. And 99% a year, don't,
when's the last time you saw a guy in a
bicycle actually stop at a fucking red
light? They never do. They never
do. They fucking look both ways.
They fucking glide right through the
fucking thing. And then if they get hit,
then they frost the bicycle. Like,
oh, can you believe that happened?
What a poor baby. Um, I dunno.
I have to tell you the people who ride
bicycles out here and in Los Angeles or
ride their fucking minds and I am so
anti those fucking cars that are going to
drive themselves.
Um,
until I go on the highways out here in
Los Angeles, I'm just like, you know what?
I really think it should be. I think
if you, if you suck at driving,
they should just take your right to
drive away. You can still have a car,
but the car will drive for you because
you suck at it. You know what I mean?
But I think if you're
actually a decent driver,
you should then be allowed
to continue driving.
So I think if you got rid of people
who suck the driving right off the bat,
conservatively speaking,
I'd say that's at least 30% of drivers,
you know? And then I think
that middle, you know,
30 the 35%,
we'll just have the option because
there's a lot of people that are actually
decent and driving. But
if they're like, dude,
if I could just fucking take a nap and
just sleep on the way to work for 45
minutes and just wake up when I there, I
would rather do that. So you figure it,
at least half of them are going to do
it initially and then a half of those
halfs are going to be like,
well he has a self driving car. I I,
you know, grass is always greener.
I want one of those two.
And then I think you'll just basically
get down to 18% of people that she truly
enjoyed driving and we'll get
our own lane book. This is my,
my drink, we get our own lane, we
get to drive as fast as we want.
And you guys had just all in robot cars,
you know,
and then everybody who actually
still continues to drive,
those are the people that, you know, when
they're the first guy to make a left,
they get way out to the intersection.
They feel a sense of responsibility that
two cars behind them, we'll make it.
Those types of people. You
know, those people that,
that realized the further left you go,
the faster you go.
And if somebody is on your bumper, you
don't slam on the brakes, she get over,
that person's, obviously I'm in
more of a here a hurry than you are.
You fucking let them go. Those were,
that's probably 18% of drivers.
Wouldn't you say you like how I just
paid it myself as the fucking heroin,
all that. Oh yeah. I'm one of the guys.
I'm one of the guys that knows how
to do the things correctly. Um,
anyways, I hope this hasn't been too
quiet. Let's plow ahead here. Um,
I am over. Oh, by the way, I'm
over the whole fucking Tom Brady.
I actually have a buddy of
mine that works in the, uh,
I can't say where he works, but just he
basically broke it down and say, listen,
this is not a personal
thing against the Patriots.
What it is is this is a corporation
thing versus the employees.
And if the corporation says this is
what's going to happen in the employee is
able to go around that,
then they get then that you got
the nuts running in the nuthouse.
So basically Tom Brady was
acquitted of any sort of cheating,
but this second trial,
yes, he was look it up.
This second trial was, or at very
least he was never convicted of that.
Um,
this second trial was,
was more about does a corporation have
a right to discipline its employees?
So you know what happened to Tom
Brady outside in the real world,
in the United States of America,
it wouldn't even have made it to trial.
All right, but with the lack of
fucking evidence that yeah, they had,
okay. The, on the other side, um,
you have within a corporation,
a corporation operates the
way a corporation operates.
So they should be allowed to run there.
But that's what it was about.
Are we as a corporation allowed
to discipline our employees?
Are they able to go
outside the corporation?
Are we going to have to
fucking deal with that?
And it was a big deal for the suits in
the NFL to win that because if Tom Brady
wins that thing,
then every fucking suspension a player
could simply take it outside of the NFL
and it really, um, whittles down
the level of power that they have.
So I got to actually be honest with you,
I actually understand now I
understand why the NFL did that.
And you know, if they got to throw Tom
Brady under the fucking bus than so be it.
Now I know a lot of you guys out there
think I'm skirting the fucking issue as
far as like, oh, he deflated. I'm not
saying it didn't deflate the fucking ball,
but that's not why the colts lost
by 35 fucking points. I said,
this is Zillion fucking times.
You know,
Andrew Luck shouldn't
even be on the colts.
The colts actually tried the season
before he was available in the draft,
but they tanked the whole
fucking season. And um, I dunno,
just the amount of attention that
Tom Brady gets versus, you know,
you know,
have an HGH delivered to your
fucking house in your wife's name.
And then you sit there in front of the
Superbowl media for two weeks and it's
not even brought up.
And then you quote Forrest Gump and
ride off into the sunset and then
everybody's cool with it. Um,
whatever, that's all I would have.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
So anyways, plowing ahead here.
Plowing ahead. Um, let me do it.
Read a little bit of advertising here
and then I'm going to get the fuck out of
here and go stare at a computer
screen. All God Damn Day. Um, on it.
Everybody. Joe Rogan's,
great company here, a Alpha
brain instant from on. It is,
it is a delicious all natural stimulant
free drink mix that helps support memory,
focus and processing speed.
The Boston Center for memory conducted
a double blind studies showing its
effectiveness. I don't know what a double
blind study is, but that sounds, uh,
that sounds like all checks
and balances Cleo. So Matt,
a buddy fucking itch and up a storm.
Um,
it's the secret weapon of pro
athletes like a Bodie, Miller,
Brian Cushing,
and Jonathan Tabes.
But anyone can benefit from the
effects of Alpha brain instant,
simply mixed a stick packet of Alpha brain
instant into a water bottle and start
feeling the effects immediately.
Um,
it's non GMO gluten free, stimulant
free made of natural ingredients.
And most importantly it works.
And as a special offer for my listeners,
special offer,
my listeners can try alpha brain instant
for free by going to [inaudible] dot
com slash bill o n n I t.com/bill to
get free samples of Alpha brain instant.
Now, Oh look who's back
club. Debbie. Debbie,
we'd been there for you.
We've been there.
You come home after a long exhausting
day at work and all you want to do is sip
a glass of wine and relax.
Get a little buzz going and
forget about your miserable life.
But unless you plan ahead,
you probably don't even have a bottling
your house and getting up and going to
the store is not happening
cause you're wiped out.
Please include all of the following
points. Why wouldn't I club Debbie?
Heck and she dropped a tear.
Um,
you can finally relax because you'll
never have to worry about being wine free
again. Up Debbie, you
can eat for one. Again.
I like Parker brothers is a revolutionary
new wine club that sends you wine
directly to your doors.
Saving all those trips to the grocery
store and not only does club Debbie it
catch it. Four o'clock, four cross.
Why am I talking about connect four?
I just pictured that's what
he does in his retirement.
He plays Parker Brother Games,
chutes and ladders connect for monopoly.
Um, send you wine. They send
you wine that you will love.
Drinking club w easy six question
quiz figures out your palate.
So every bottle you receive is perfectly
tailored to your tastes club. Debbie,
I love playing the Banjo. Works directly
with vineyards to cut out the middleman,
which saves you money.
Clip Debbie and fulfill my brother
champ even though he's out of it,
even offers a no risk guarantee that
you'll love. Um, and you'll love Yo.
You'll guarantee that you'll love
what they send you. Right now,
club w is offering my listeners
20 $20 off your first order.
When you go to club Debbie,
a.com/burr and it gets even better.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So club w will actually pay for shipping
on orders of four, four bottles or more.
So take something off your to do list.
Just go to club w.
Dot com slash bird to get
$20 off your first order.
Now that's clubbed Debbie at.com/burr.
All right,
couple more here and I just scrolled down.
Oh,
zip recruiter.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect car,
you need to post your job on all the
top job sites. And now you can, uh,
with sip.
Okay,
but growed up.com you can post
your jobs to 100 plus job sites,
including social media, including
networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click. Find candidates
in any city or industry nationwide.
Just once.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface. No juggling
emails or calls in your office.
Quickly scan candidates, rate them,
and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has
been used by over 800,000 businesses.
And right now listeners can try zip.
Okay.
For free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/decode that's
ZipRecruiter slash.com/burr
one more time,
ziprecruiter.com/berm all right,
what do I got left to? How many? How
many are I read these last two later?
I'll tell you, I read them
later, you know, um, oh,
congratulations to the
meet me in St Louis.
Louis meet me at the fair St Louis Blues,
got the job done.
Um, what a fucking huge
one for that city. Um,
that's always great to see that,
but it was instantly also depressing
not to see Chicago when it, because uh,
then need, you don't get
to watch, you know, all the
great players that they have,
tapes, cane, Dunkin keys
and all those guys. Um,
it's weird to see the Black Hawks and
the kings out in the first round and look
who's coming up on the outside.
Now this French sake of San Jose sharks,
the fucking,
I mean their logo should literally be
somebody choking on a piece of fucking
steak. You know, I don't know why
steak but just choking on something.
I don't think you could find a team that's
won more hockey games and left in the
first round or just not want a cup.
I don't know what it is
about the San Jose sharks.
I just don't have any sympathy for them
or their fucking fence. I don't know why.
I think it has to do with that teal
color that they have. You know,
maybe it's cause the kings got
rid of their, their fucking,
you know, royal colors,
the Laker colors that they had
and they took basically black,
white and gray because you know,
you'd think the sharks would
have like a gray looking uniform.
You think if you had, like, if he came
up with a killer name, like the sharks,
like that animal, that fish there
was just sitting there on the table.
Because you know, you know the
deal with sports teams, there's,
there's only so many ferocious fucking
animals to pick from. You know,
and then once that goes out the window,
then you kind of got to talk about
like the jobs people do. Like a,
with the packers.
Yeah.
Everybody pack stuff up here and where
the fucking these guys or those guys,
you know,
and then when you're really out of names,
that's when you start naming teams after
like weather, right? The higher change,
the heat, the thunder, right.
The mysteries, whatever the fuck you
come, flurries the Florida flurries,
that wouldn't make sense. It
doesn't snow down there. Um,
Florida Sun showers,
it's just really going to be bad.
That's why you can't go beyond 30 teams
and he's fucking leak, you know, or 32,
I guess that's where we're up to.
But sharks was just sitting there,
just sitting there on the
table. And I remember thinking
like, Oh wow, the shocks,
it's a great name. I can't wait to see
that uniform. And it was like, bump,
bump a bomb. Ooh, it's a shark. And he's
biting a hockey stick and half. Well,
yeah, then you're going to get a penalty
for, for slashing and today's Nhl,
right. Second, the stick
breaks automatically. Um,
I'm sorry. I don't know.
I don't know what it is. I just don't, uh,
this is where I have
sympathy for the shark fans.
I know what it's like to root for a
fucking team year in and year out and they
fucking blow it. I don't know what
it's like for the last 15 years.
All of a sudden my hell turned into a,
a fucking paradise because everybody
started fucking winning. But before then,
you know,
I was a red sox fan living in New York
City with all that curse of the Babe Shit
going on, you know, Boston sports,
we're in the fucking shitter.
Basically.
When I was growing up,
we had the Boston Celtics and then
up to 86 and then once Len bias died,
um, and then Reggie Lewis died. I
mean, the whole thing just, it just,
the wheels fell off for like
20 fucking years. But um,
fortunately nowadays you can go out and
buy a championship, which we did in 2007.
Um, anyways, so I'm just trying to
say congratulations to St Louis.
Now my two favorite teams out west,
the stars and the blues are
playing each other and um,
I think I'm going to stick with
the blues just cause I don't know,
I just worked St Louis,
I saw how excited they were and you know,
I like the stars because I used to like
the Minnesota north stars and I liked
the people on the stars,
but I'm not into their fans either.
You Know Dallas fans,
at the end of the fucking day,
you don't give a fuck about the stars.
There's only one star in Dallas and
that's the one on the side of the cowboys
helmet. You know, it's
fucking true yet out.
That's all you give a fuck about this
beautiful ladies coming out and they're
little hoary cherries.
Charlie's angel outfits.
That's what you give a fuck about that.
You give a fuck about that.
And your shiny four door pickup
truck that's never seen dirt, right?
Come in there with your
fake tid fucking botox,
Dolly Parton fucking hair check going
down the street looking like a couple of
televangelists. That's what you do
out there in Dallas in the big D.
Isn't that what you do? I know.
I'm just fucking with you. Um,
the one great thing though, I
do like, you know, something,
I can't say I'm totally anti
technology because uh, I do love Tivo,
but back in the day I also had a
VCR so I could've take games. Right?
I'm saying like the one
great thing that you,
thing that I have in the writer's
room as we're doing all the work no,
is the excitement was
right around five o'clock.
I know we only got a couple hours left
and that whatever game I want to watch is
currently being taping and that being
taped and I don't go on Twitter.
I don't look at my phone or anything
that I had just shut it off and uh,
I'm able to come home and watch all
these fucking great series and uh,
it's just the best, you know,
actually retweeted those civic,
you guys see that thing on Twitter?
Not that dude becoming a hockey fan.
It's fucking black dude is hilarious.
Like he goes, you know what,
I'm going to give this hockey shit to try.
And he just starts live tweeting game
seven of the blues and the Black Caucus
and I guess he decided to root for the
blues and he was just tweeting this
hilarious shit.
Like what the fuck is a power play?
I don't know who this cane guy is,
but we got to stop this motherfucker.
And then towards the end
of the game he goes, what?
So like the goalie just leaves.
Then the best question he ever asked,
I've ever heard a hockey goes for real.
Why don't, why doesn't the whole other
team just stand in front of that net?
You know when you're up by one and the
just shooting like, why don't you do that?
That's fucking hilarious.
Um,
that's just someone who's never gotten
hit in the foot with the fucking puck.
It's like you really went up, I watched
somebody block a shot like I just,
the fucking balls that that takes
you do that and pick up hockey.
You're going to be limping for the rest
of the fucking week to watch these guys
blocking NHL shot. They're
out of their minds. But, um,
anyways, I'm up to 30 minutes here. I
got to kind of cut this thing short.
I know I usually do a little bit more
time than this, but I gotta I gotta go,
I gotta go to work. Oh,
Billy goes to work every day.
Eight a fucking salad every day at lunch.
That's what I do.
They like a big fucking pussy
every fucking day. Um, and
I'm actually doing okay.
And I tried to lose two pounds this week,
which I think I did,
but I had a Burrito last night,
so I only lost like a fucking pounds.
So next week I have to be down to one 76
going to buckle down over this weekend
and fucking workout and um,
get myself back down to about a buck 70.
Um, by the way, I think the
Celtics a playing tonight,
I think game six, that's obviously
a must win. We're winning at home,
but we're getting pounded.
We got fucking pounded that last game.
It's like a joke or is almost we almost
losing by fucking 30 but you know,
we're a young team. We'll see hopefully
next year with all our draft picks.
Maybe we'll get Kevin Durant or that
uni brow guy from fucking New Orleans.
Although I don't think either
one of those are good. You know,
as far as for the league,
I think to ranch should stay in Oklahoma
and I think uni brow guys should stay
in New Orleans. Doesn't that make sense?
My out of my fucking mind to think that,
that if you come in with the team,
Yada fucking,
unless that fucking you over like Shaq,
Shaq should have stayed with the magic,
you know, shouldn't it came out and
just piled on with the fucking Lakers?
Look what happened.
You went a couple of championships and
then he threw out his neck celebrating as
he went down. The Courtney
was never the same. All right,
let me do a couple more reads here and
then I gotta get Outta here. All right,
hallux. He likes h. E. L. I. X.
What is it about buying a mattress
that leaves you feeling violated? Well,
I dunno what the fuck happened to you
at the store? Jesus Christ. It violated.
That's a really strong word.
Especially when you have a mattress.
I was phased out.
I heard them unbuckle his pants.
Um, is it, is it the pushy sales people,
the fake president day sales or the fact
that you know you'll regret what you
bought as you do the walk of shame out of
the mattress store these days are over.
Thanks to helic sleep where
you can buy a mattress online,
customized for you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousand,
go to [inaudible] dot
com he looks whatever,
answer a few simple
questions and he looks,
creates your custom sleep profile to build
you the perfect mattress. The results,
our customers report a 30% improvement
in overall sleep. All right,
and you want to fill in the other 70%.
Don't drink, don't drink any booze.
You'll sleep like a baby.
Your mattress will arrive at your door
in about a week and shipping is 100%
free. You have 100 nights to try
it out. And if you don't love it,
they'll pick you up for free and give
you 100% refund. No questions asked.
It's like it never happened.
If you do love your new helux mattress,
keep it and your dignity.
Uh,
that's why everyone from
Gq magazine and Forbes,
they're all talking about helix sleep.
Go to hell.
It's sleep.com/burn and
get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar hey
helic sleep.com/birth all right.
I said it both ways throughout the
whole thing. All right, tracker,
fucking train tracker, smartphones,
smack cast, Matt Holmes.
Technology has made everything smart,
but losing his stuff's still
makes people feel really stupid.
Tracker makes losing things. That thing
of the past tracker is a called tracker.
I they haven't said it enough.
Here.
Tracker is a coin size device that
locates misplaced keys, wallets, bags,
computers, anything in seconds. Just
pair of tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find his
precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. Why don't I have
one of these fucking things?
I lose my phone all the time.
Lose your phone. There you go.
Press the button on tracker and your
phone rings even when it's on silent with
over 1.5 million devices tracker as the
largest crowd gps network in the world.
So your last item shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything again.
With track are listeners to this show.
Get a special discount, 30% off your
entire order. Go to the spelled t,
h e t r a C K e r.com and
enter Promo code bird.
The hardest thing you'll ever
have to do is find their website.
Go to the tracker.com.
Go to the tracker.com right now and
enter a promo code birth for 30% off your
entire order. That's the highest
I've ever heard off anything. Again,
that is the tracker.com
Promo Code [inaudible].
It's like the Ohio State University,
um,
which at the end of the
day is just a state school,
so they should get over themselves. All
right, that's a podcast for this Thursday.
Have a wonderful weekend.
You cons.
If our you're protesting and you want
my support, stay up on the sidewalk.
If you're riding a bicycle,
please be careful and ride single file
and have some fucking courtesy for the
people behind you. And if there's a red
light, why don't you fucking stop it?
The thing. Okay. It stopped wearing
aerodynamic shit. All right.
It doesn't make you any faster and you,
there's nothing at stake. All right.
All right. Enjoy the music and the,
uh, the highlights from podcasts.
True.
Hey,
what's going on the Monday morning podcast
that I'm doing it seven 30
at night Pacific coast time.
So it's still 10 30 on east
coast. So it's still Monday. Uh,
it's going on with me. I'm cooking
fish. It's what I'm doing right now.
Cooking fish.
And I'm steaming some Broccoli cause
I have to be in shape next week.
Why you ask?
Because on November 10th,
I'm taping my one hour comedy special,
uh, for a DVD. I, you like that segue
right out of the fish and Broccoli,
right into the goddamn comedy.
Jesus Christ. I'm a professional.
Um, and this is the deal, man. I just, if
you guys want to go, the tickets are free.
Yes, they are free. All right. And, uh,
I sent out a bulletin and a,
one of the problems I'm having is,
um,
I you have to do,
you just go to Belper at Broadway video
and just write bill burrs and capitals,
Bill Burr at Broadway video.
Just request your tickets,
leave your name and your phone number.
It's all in the bulletin. But you know,
people don't like to read.
So what they're doing is they're
reading the first quarter of it and then
they're sending me the
email with their name,
with their requests and their
phone numbers. So the comedian,
I'm going to have to call
them and say some stupid shit.
Now I don't have those tens of minutes
for my phone. What the fuck am I kidding?
I think I had the worst plan ever.
I probably made like seven phone calls
last month and I've got a $380 cell phone
bill screamed like a bitch
echoed in my fucking living room.
Um, yeah. So that's the deal. So, uh,
anybody in the New York City area that
wants to come out or I don't know if
you're going to be in New York
and you want to come down. Um,
I'm taping my special and I obviously
don't want to take my special in front of
40 people.
Uh,
it's a nice big theater
and nice and cushy and uh,
I want to make you laugh so seriously.
Go to bill burr at Broadway,
video.com to get your tickets.
And uh, with that I think I'm done. Um,
I think I'm done whoring out my stuff.
Is that it?
I don't know. It's like I got
one other thing here. Goddammit.
I'm never organized for these things.
Really.
Not My cds available on a
God. Listen to the little balls right now.
This is fucking brutal. Oh, here we go.
Yeah.
People who want to get the extra,
the extra or the bonus material on my CV.
Just go to a,
what are records.com
backslash?
I can't speak this computer shit.
What are records.com backslash [inaudible]
backslash this God discography?
Discog once you say a d disco
and then Graffy. How about that?
D I. S D I. S. C o.
G R. A. P. H Y. Dot.
Html.
Is anybody out there scrolling that down
like fucking radar O'Reilly right now?
Um, all right. Yeah, so that's the deal.
So I got my DVD taping is on December,
November 10th
November 10th this is the,
I am the worst at this shit and the
worst at this shit. If you know what,
just go on my page.
If you click down,
what it's going to do is it's
going to take you to my website.
It's going to take you on a little journey
to a place I called [inaudible] dot
com and you just click on upcoming shows
and then just click on November 17th
and then you don't have to
listen to me anymore. In fact,
just hit stop and just do that right now
and there won't be any more confusion.
Just read the whole email though,
and bill burr at Broadway video.
All right there.
I said at 98 times,
then I just make my fucking
Broccoli all soggy. I did.
Who Steamed Broccoli and does a
podcast. You know, who does I do. I do.
You think Rodney Dangerfield of it?
Did some shit like that.
I mean probably do some blow,
but it was the 80s. Okay.
I would have been on blow if
it was the 80 [inaudible].
Now I'm just on crystal
meth. Hey. Oh, last, uh,
last time I did a podcast also
people said, you know, these things,
I just sort of meander. Know
I cook, I cook fish, I a,
I seem shit.
I drive my car and you know,
I got a new people I'm running out
of stuff to talk about. You know?
I really thought that my
life was interesting enough
that once a week I could
babble about it for 10 minutes.
And you know what?
I realize nobody's at interesting.
Nobody is that fucking interesting.
You know, like how I did that. Rather
than just taking it myself and just say,
you know what? I'm really
not that interesting. A guy.
I dragged everybody down with me,
including you. Listen to this.
I even said that you are not that
interesting. You realize that what a Dick.
Right. All right, so people
sent me some questions.
I'm going to try to answer
these things honestly,
if I count so you can get
to know me a little bit.
All right. Where did this
guy, right? This Guy Brad,
the fuck names a kick, Brad. You
know what I mean? That's like,
you don't even give a shit. It's not.
It's like you don't want to be popular.
You don't want him to get the shit kicked
out of him. He just, it was just like,
you know, do you want fries? Yeah. Yeah.
Like a fries. What do you want to see?
What do you want to call it,
kid? Hey Brad. Yeah, Brad is,
Brad wants to know,
do you ever feel like you have time off?
Wait a sec. I can't read
out loud that. Well.
Do you ever feel like you have time off
or does everyone you meet expect you to
make them laugh on call
Brad?
You know what, that fucking sentence
goes in three different directions.
It's like when a plane is doing an s
pattern because there's too many God damn
people in the world and they don't
want to go into a holding pattern.
That's what you're fucking,
you just did the DVD.
I don't know the sentence version
of my fucking flight into Newark.
Do you ever feel like you have time off?
I think it's going to be about going
on vacation or does everyone you meet
expect you to make them laugh
on call the mean on Cue bread.
But I got a question for you.
Where the fuck did you go to school
and learn how to communicate?
Thought two sentences. Is that a run on
it? No, it isn't. I don't think it is.
Do you ever feel like you have time off
or does everyone you meet expect you to
make them laugh on call on call?
Like what am a nursing you
asking me if I do like, uh,
like benefits for sick people?
Yeah, I do. I do those,
I know what he's saying.
He do you have you ever feel like you can
just relax and not be a Zany douchebag?
Yeah. Offstage? Uh, yeah, I, I don't,
I don't walk around with
a lampshade on my head,
if that's what you were asking me.
Um, I actually know, I do find,
I find people try to make me laugh and
they come up to me and they tell me
horrific jokes
and then when they're done with them,
if I can even guess when they're done.
That's the worst part is when somebody
tells you a joke and it's so bad,
you still think they're
in the middle of it.
So you're still sitting there with your
eyebrows up. You know, when you do that,
when you're, when you're, you're trying,
like when you know somebody sucks,
whatever they're doing
sucks, but you don't have the
balls to just stare at them.
Like your story sucks, but you
can't fake like, it's interesting.
So the only way to do it,
you just put your eyebrows up
like, uh Huh. Yeah. Uh Huh.
And then he's just staring at you and
it's over and you're sitting there with
your eyebrows up by your fucking hair
line and you realize that your moment to
laugh was, uh, it has come and gone.
That's what I have had people tell me.
They tell me awful,
awful jokes and then they tell me about
some guy they work with and be and
they're like, oh my God, you,
you got to put this in your act.
I went with this Guy Mac,
right.
And every day each chicken
salad and then pictures,
picture fucking 20 minutes of that
as you're standing in an airport trying
to hear when they're boarding zone seven
or whatever the fuck they work it out
because that's what ends up happening.
So no, I don't feel like
I have to be on offstage.
I just try to chill out and uh,
I certainly don't do it around my family
cause anytime I even remotely fit funny
around my family, they break
my balls. They don't even
laugh to just go, oh really?
That's good bill. You're going to
put that in your act. It count.
Um, okay. That was question number one.
And I guess that's how
I'm going to do them.
I'm going to make fun of how people ask
me questions and I'm going to shit on
their lives because I'm not happy with
my own on some fucked up level. Oh fuck.
Seven 55. How much a
fisherman it though? Uh,
what kind of fish and I think
it's called Talia, I don't know.
Get some lemon zest on it or something.
I Dunno what the fuck it is.
I'm eating like a, uh, an
Asian in a communist country.
People who are in Greek,
God Damn Shit. Unless time
yourself fat Asian. Honestly,
the only time you ever see a fat Asian,
they're hanging out with other white
people and they're walking out of
Mcdonald's. So if anybody
Asian is listening, stop
hanging out with us because uh,
you know, nine out of 10 of us are
going to a fucking cuckoo room.
Um, all right. Uh, okay.
This brings me to my question.
Here is this guy, what is this?
What is your worst slash funniest
experience in dealing with the comedy club
owner?
I also,
have you ever broken the news to a
comedian that he just isn't that funny?
If not, how often you want
to, that's a great question.
Um, as far as the club owners, the worst
in front of his experiences, too many,
too many of them.
Uh,
the most recently is I worked for
this psycho up in Seattle who, uh,
he brings me into town. He's going to pay
me a disgusting amount of money, right?
So I need to sell tickets and this
guy doesn't advertise the show at all,
so I don't sell any tickets.
So then he yells at my management
company, you know, I mean,
even if you had Jesus Christ
plan at your club, you know,
you couldn't just put his name out on
the marquee and have somebody, you know,
you need at least have to have somebody
with a fucking sandwich board walking up
and down the street to let, let you know
that the son of God is down the street.
Jesus Christ would have a difficult time
selling out a club without advertising.
He'd have to be doing
miracles on the corner.
Like one of those fucking David blame
guys hanging upside down in a cube of ice
or some shit. Trying to get people to come
down there. Okay, that's the son of God.
That's what he would have to do. Okay,
now you're talking about little old me,
right?
But thank God this Guy Marty reamer up
there put me on the radio and then we
sold a bunch of tickets and then the guy,
you know,
he does like a one 80 and all of a sudden
he loves me and he's one of these guys.
He's such as psycho.
I don't even care if he fucking,
here's this because he's
a psycho and psychos have,
they don't, they don't remember
anything. He'll be mad.
They know throw a stapler at his assistant
that he's underpaying and then he'll
come to like when David banner
comes back from being the hall can,
you won't even remember that
I said this shit. All right.
So if you are listening all that shit
you said to my management company,
it got back to me.
Okay.
Fucking fucking psycho. Psycho. He had
a comb over to God. Those are the worst.
Who Do you think you're
fooling? Um, all right.
Oh, the other one. Have you ever broken
the news to a comedian that he just,
isn't that funny? If not, how often do
you want to, I'll tell you right now,
I would never do that to somebody.
I, uh, I don't think
somebody is funny. I just,
I keep it to myself because there's been
a lot of people who've really sucked
for a long time and then all of a
sudden they figure out how to be funny.
And, uh, I dunno.
I look at everybody like they're
like me when I started out with who,
other than when I started out,
I had no confidence and a,
you know,
I,
if one person is some established
comedian came up to me and said that they
didn't wait a minute, somebody did
that. Somebody did come up to me.
That's right.
It is Vietnam comedy flashback.
I was working then the comedy
in Boston, Massachusetts. This,
how long ago was,
I had a big Red Afro.
I was wearing a striped shirt with
a vest member in the mid nineties.
He's white. His grunge was starting
to die, but it was before in sync.
And the boy band thing,
it's sorta a letter on like the sublime
era and that people like for half a
second,
we're willing to invest.
It's just one of those that's like
when black people try to make a pink,
that color member,
they were like,
subs were wearing tank for
like a week and a half.
I remember seeing that thinking if black
people pull this off, that's, that's it.
That's a game set match. There was
nothing that they cannot make. Cool.
And that shit went away real quick.
Well,
the white version of that was vests.
Okay.
I know a lot of people
fucking laughing at you,
but if there's other people my age
out there, late 30, [inaudible] to 40,
you remember it, you had
it on and uh, you know,
it's right after doc Martins.
It was the bridge, the vest. Oh,
I get to the fucking point of the story.
Jesus Christ. All right. So anyways,
so that's what I'm wearing.
I go on stage and I kill and I get off
stage and then there's other comedian
comes up and he's like,
he's a red head too,
but he's like 60 years old.
He's basically me in 40 years at the
time when he came up to me and uh,
and he just came up to me and he
just like, you know what I mean,
you to set up there, then it
was all bullshit. You know,
you just day you're jumping
around and blah, blah blah.
And he just shit all over my act.
You know,
you have a watch the discovery channel
with some sort of fucking Willdabeast
trying to market to territory.
That's what he did to my act. And uh,
everything he was saying was
like a punch through my chest,
pass my heart and into my soul and uh,
it was fucking brutal.
Then I still had a day job,
so I had to go back to work for
like three days before my next show.
And all I'm hearing in my head is this
guy's voice telling me that I suck.
And like back then I had
such little confidence,
I just took what anybody
said to me as law.
So they said I sucked and I sucked. I
didn't have the brains to be like, well,
it's just an old bitter comic. He used
to be a young red head and now you know,
a not so young anymore. And uh, you know,
he's a little drunk and he's been a
Douche. This has nothing to do with me.
I didn't know how to do that back then.
I was like, oh my God, somebody would,
TV credits thinks I suck,
so therefore I must suck.
So whatever, fast forward,
that's why I'd never do it to somebody.
I would never do that.
I wouldn't want to make somebody feel
like that. Now if you heckle me, you know,
all bets are off. I don't give
a shit. I wants to make you, uh,
just short of suicidal. I'm sure
that's kind of childish. But, uh,
that's it. So to answer your question
now, I don't say that and uh,
I gotta be honest with you.
I hate watching people bond
and unless it's my friends,
if it's a friend of mine and who's funny
and I watched him go up there and try a
new joke,
especially if it's a high energy
joke and they end with this big Ted,
I look on their face and they get nothing.
I can tell you that
nothing makes a comedian.
The civilian version of that
is watching a good friend.
He goes fall down a flight of stairs.
I mean it's just fucking hilarious.
No matter even if they dislocate
their shoulder or whatever, you know,
at some point as you're
driving them to the hospital,
you're going to have to turn and look
out the driver's side window and you,
you got to kind of laugh.
You know this, you know,
you do it subtly cause you're like him.
He's your friend, right? Jesus Christ.
Could I take longer to answer a fucking
question? Was trying to get quicker.
Uh, where do we go here?
What do we got next?
When are we getting the next one? It's
a couple more of these. All right. Um,
what's your most embarrassing moment
on stage or in life? Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
I block them out at this point.
Had somebody throw a dinner roll at me.
Does that count?
Dental floss thrown at me? If you look
on my website, I get fucking somebody
who a doughnut at me. I mean, I dunno. So
he sold ice had me, uh, I, you know what,
probably the first time I bombed
in front of an all black crowd.
Maybe that was the fucking, that was the
worst famine in front of a white crowd.
Sucks enough.
But like you just feel like you suck,
but when you bomb and you're the only
white guy in the room when you bomb it and
you really feel like you're bombing for
the entire white race and you're also
reinforcing the stereotype
that white people aren't funny.
And it was just the worst. And I was
standing up there first job bombed.
I ran to the second joke,
the next joke bombed.
At this point I have like dry mouth,
like I can't even explain it.
Just, you know when like concrete,
I dunno when it gets so dry you can,
you can break it off and it seemed that,
you know that little powdered miss.
Just imagine if you just took a whole
handful of I'm stuck in, in your mouth.
That's how dry my mouth was and for
some reason no one was heckling.
They would just sort of sitting
there just looking around is it,
the show hadn't even started,
which it had been.
It'd been going great for like an hour
and I went into my third joke in total
panic mode, trapped in my act,
just mobile, blah blah blah,
blah,
blabbing on.
And then all of a sudden in
the back is big black girl.
He cheating on those voices. She
didn't, she wasn't even saying it loud,
but if you could just a hot summer day
and it just carried throughout the club.
As I'm up there babbling
on in dead silence,
I just hear her clear as day just go,
I ain't left yet.
And the whole place just started laughing.
It was like a whole nother show was
going on while I was still up there in my
act and I was so green.
I didn't know what to do when I should
have done was addressing, but I didn't.
I continue doing my act, which made
them laugh at me even more. It was,
it was absolutely humiliating,
but I got to admit,
I didn't really think about it until
you asked me that fucking question.
So either I'm over it or I'm
just the only complete denial.
Okay. Why are you still single? Uh,
cause I'm a psycho and
if you don't know that,
listen to my podcasts. Listen
to this one, right? I'll fight.
I keep forgetting to take the Goddamn
Fisher. Um, anyways. All right.
I think it's time for me to eat
like an Asian in a communist country.
I tell him, if you want to get shredded,
man, that's what I'm telling you, man.
You don't want to fucking fuck all these
stupid other diets. One of the that did
the South Beach, Manhattan beach,
it's always like a beach, right?
All that bullshit. You don't need
to do that. That's what you do.
You eat like somebody in Asia just
squatting down on the side of the road in
some Zen, like, you know those
Buddhist monks, you know,
you ever seen a fat monkey?
You just don't see it.
A Buddhist monk. Okay,
but you got those friar tuck white
ones. The fat man. It's just,
I don't know what it is.
It sits up.
We got that double cheeseburger
thing going on, you know, but, uh,
I, you know what, I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about this point.
All right, so I'm going
to wrap this up. Uh,
I want to thank everybody who listened
to in called into the uninformed show.
Uh, the, the radio show I do
with Joe to Rosa. And, uh,
that's quickly becoming one of the most
fun things that I do here. And, uh,
and the entertainment world.
We did a Halloween show and real quick,
so we had on a, uh, a real live, which,
and a couple of people from the Church
of Satan because we wanted to learn about
that shit. And I get, it was unbelievable.
They were the most boring fucking people.
I've New People in the Church of Satan
evidently don't believe in the devil.
The, they just don't like. Nah.
The Church of Satan is just giving into
the desires you want to be and do and
yeah. You know, I stop at Red Lights
and a, I yield to pedestrians.
It was the most excruciating hour
of radio I think I've ever done.
But we did have the drum battle.
Me and Joe to Rosa,
uh, go to uninformed radio.com.
Later on this week, we have the, uh,
the video up Joe one the
plane through the song part,
and then I won the freestyle so you can
vote and see which one of us is better.
You know, it's, I know it's kind of
fucking gay, but we had a good time. Um,
so that's it.
I'm going to be in Las Vegas on
November 17th doing at Caesar's palace.
Jeez, it's so beautiful in here,
isn't it? I wish I had a toga.
Fucking hate casinos. They have
the ugliest goddamn rugs. I mean,
the what they must pay per
square footage for a casino rug.
If it's just fucking, it's mind
boggling. How ugly it is, you know,
got the bid yet.
Drink it.
Why didn't I buy those myths to help you
take a hot plate out and you guys won't
listen to me. Take a hot plate
out with a couple of districts.
I can burn myself and the fucking
podcast him. See if this is,
don't fuck. Ow. Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow,
ow. Shit done. You know the worst
thing about cooking a white fish?
You have no fucking idea
when has done right.
You know what?
I think I'm really trashy.
White people on this may
find Asians a little bit.
I'm talking about how fucking fat
white people are and uh, wait a second,
is that done? Oh Shit. That's gone. Look
at debt. Oh, would you look at that?
If I was Emeril right now, Emeril
Lagasse I, I would fucking,
I would take some chocolate chips and
throw them on top and go back and start
screaming just to get the crowd going.
I fucking hate that show. All right.
If you want to watch [inaudible] who
got you watched the essence of Emma?
Cause then he's just
sitting there cooking.
If you watch Emeril live or
whatever his show is to do,
he, he's like, he's got to entertain
people. Once you have a studio audience,
do you have noticed that? Then all of
a sudden you just got to dumb it down.
You can't cook anymore. Now you've
got to be like, I got some shit.
Everybody starts applauding. Like they
can't afford it. They know it's sugar.
Okay? You get it for
free at a diner, right?
You're not kicking it up a notch.
You making people fatter
and you contributing to the
diabetes and this goddamn
country. All right Emma. So why don't
you fucking take it down a few notches.
And uh, what about the musicians? He
actually has musicians on that show.
Jesus Christ. And you know, when you
start out to be a musician, you think,
you know, I dunno, you're
gonna to fucking play arenas.
But if you're going to do the TV thing,
maybe you'll be in the Conan
band or the tonight show band.
You really don't think you're going to be
playing your flute while,
you know,
in between some guy teaching
somebody how to make Lasagna.
Why does she make me feel better about
myself and my career? Anyways, that's it.
Go to bill burr at Broadway,
video.com for the tickets. Uh,
police come out to the show.
I've got a lot of new stuff.
I haven't been in New York for
a minute and uh, come on down.
Seven 45, November 10th.
Come down an hour early.
I will make you laugh. That is what
I do. So that's it guys. All right,
keep the questions,
comment. Oh wait a minute.
Congratulations to the Boston red sox.
We wanted again.
And uh,
I want to apologize to every other team
in the league that isn't the red sox or
the Yankees, cause that's all that
ESPN seems to talk about. I mean,
it's ridiculous.
I mean,
we want it last night and I just sit
through 20 minutes a shit of what that
means to the god Damn Yankees. Who gives
a fuck? What does it mean to the Indians?
What does it mean to the angels? What does
it mean to fucking them? Other people,
they don't count. They
don't count. You know,
that's how ESPN treats
the rest of the league.
They treat the red sox and
the Yankees like they're,
they're real kids and they treat
everybody else like stepchildren.
It's like you have to see that family
that adopted those kids and they kept the
check and they didn't feed the kids
and they said they're regular kids.
You know, if ESPN adopted children,
that's, that's what they do.
Doesn't even fucking make sense.
Not yet.
My is all soggy kids there anything
worse than that? Now when you do that,
what you've done is you've boiled
all the new nutrients out of it.
So what I'm doing here is I'm
just eating green, soggy shit.
That's disgusting. The fish is great
though. Fish is great. All right.
There's a lesson for you. Never Seen
Broccoli when you're doing a podcast.
All right. Come on down to my taping. If
you can't make that come out to Vegas,
you can't make that.
I'll probably end up in your area.
Please send me more questions.
Thank you everybody for listening
and giving a shit about that.
What I do means a lot to me.
Have a great week.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].